Let's go to.
OK.
I'm in it.
Oh.
Is on the phone.
I think I remember the pronounced pronunciation
here.
Aliza Medusa Okafor is joining us from the
5 1 3.
Did I get that right?
Brog it's only some maybe were at least some
madu.
OK, all right.
Next time I'm going to do it.
All good.
David, how are you doing today?
Good.
What's going on?
Oh, yeah.
I was looking at some tweets this morning
in Michigan and Nevada, and I mean, I have
to be out of that kind of scares the crap
out of me about, you know, the president's,
you know, thinking about, you know, extorting
states.
I mean, I think what are the judges who were
in the impeachment trial?
He literally had an example of the bridge.
And, you know, this is just like another example
of, you know, just extorting states to do
what he wants.
I mean, we're in the middle of a global pandemic.
And I think I just wonder how, you know, not
just like the tweet itself, but like how well,
like is, you know, I guess, animosity towards
absentee ballot voting.
Like will, you know, be a thing like will
you start it like limiting people from voting?
Yes.
So it's just just so people know that this
what Trump tweeted was Michigan sends absentee
ballots to 7.7 million people ahead of primaries
and general election.
This was done illegally and without authorization
by a rogue secretary of state.
I will ask to hold up funding to Michigan
if they want to go down this voter fraud path.
This is this is a totalitarian nightmare potentially
that's shaping up here, because remember,
Trump always talks about federalism, the power
of the states, all of this stuff.
States are totally within their light.
Right, to decide how they want to run their
elections.
And in fact, the presidential election is
not a national election.
It's 50 state elections.
And if states want to do vote by mail, they
can do it.
They're allowed to do that.
So when Trump says, I don't like it and I
might not give them money.
This is exactly the type of constitutional
crisis that unless we really are sure that
we can trust in our systems of checks and
balances, which we can't be sure of right
now, Trump could actually get away with and
it could be absolutely destructive.
It's horrifying what he's doing, what he's
saying anyway.
But that did not make me feel better.
No, no, I mean, listen, I don't want it.
I don't.
I'm not.
You all know I'm not alarmist, but so.
So, like, for example, Trump, if he loses
in November, will probably say it was rigged,
but he is going to leave like he's not gonna
physically resist it.
So I want to be reasonable with people this
stuff.
Trump is now threatening on the vote by mail
is genuinely scary.
Even.
And then I do have another question.
I don't know if you've been looking at the
news about this, but there's news about a
cyber criminal group that allegedly like hacked
Trump's law firm in New York, and they said
that they had bad days.
Honestly, I think that it was like a load
of B.S.
But apparently somebody like got a hold of
somebody like paid the ransom.
Hacking's the money to like get a hold of
the data.
But I mean, I don't know who.
So I was wondering if, you know, you could
share some thoughts on that story.
I actually I don't know anything about that.
I haven't even heard of that.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, well, that's OK.
I'll look into it.
All right.
Thank you.
Really appreciate the call.
Great to hear from you.
All right.
Take care, Will.
I'm sure hear from 0 again.
Next time, I'll get his name right.